hi everyone this is bruno azuza and
today i'm excited to introduce you to
a catalog of reference patterns these
are
code guidance that are going to help you
take advantage of
multiple products so bigquery data flow
pub sub
looker or ai platform in the context of
your business needs so what do i mean by
that well
let's say you're trying to build a
product recommendation system
or are you trying to predict your
prospects for penn city dubai
well you have the opportunity to use
these solutions if you will
to accelerate your deployment we've
learned this from some of the best
customers we've worked with
and today we're making those references
available to you now to tell you how
they work and how you can take advantage
of this
i've invited robert saxey on my team
who's joining us from amsterdam to talk
to you about them so
first robert thank you for taking the
time so late in your day
let's start at the top what are these
patterns these reference patterns
um they they cover the kind of spectrum
of
um use cases that we've we've we've seen
at different customers
so let's give some examples anomaly
detection let's say that you have
you're a telco and you're you know
monitoring the
the system logs coming from your calls
and you want to make sure that all the
traffic on your
network is you know doing you know
proper things you might
want to spot like a bad actor someone
that's going to ddos one of your
services for example
so seeing those anomalies that has real
value and with the technologies
that we make available in the cloud
today we've seen how customers put these
things together
and then rather than have you know every
customer go out there and start
you know from the beginning we want to
give them a kind of you know
a leap start let's say and give them
like 70 percent
get them 70 of the way there so think um
as you mentioned we we bring that the
code sample data
um instructions on both why the pattern
is useful and how to use the pattern how
to
run the sample and then how to customize
it and really importantly how to
activate it
one of the things i've seen that i think
is really important is when you're in
analytics spaces you're getting all
these good insights
once you've got those insights the next
part is how to operationalize it how to
take the the the results of that work
and actually
activate it and make it work for you and
put the automation in there
so you can start using you know the
other folks in your company to work on
the next things
that is great so in fact today we have a
video from polong that's going to talk
about product recommendation
you know if i'm a customer out there it
actually it's a halloween video so it's
also fun to uh
to watch if i'm a customer out there
what can i expect from that resource in
particular yeah so let's take a step
back and think about what a
recommendation is so
um you know during this um this this
prolonged period of uh partial lockdowns
and things
i found myself doing you know more diy
and then i go online and i
buy the you know the next tool or the
thing i need and
often when you buy a product or a
service there are some recommendations
there like for example if you buy a
drill
then they might suggest you some drill
bits that you know will help you
drill through wood or metal or something
like that but there's a whole bunch of
stuff they could suggest you know you
could suggest an
extra battery or something now obviously
you know some folks compile these lists
manually using their you know their
specialist knowledge that they have
about the area
but now imagine that you don't have a
catalogue of you know tens of products
or hundreds you have
thousands or tens of thousands and
rather than trying to compile you know
recommendation lists for all these
products you know these tens of
thousands of products
why not you let your customer website
behavior
for example actually drive that so we've
recorded with a recommendation system
we're looking at the feedback that we
get from customers whether it's either
explicit or implicit
implicit is the one we're going after
here because what we're trying to do is
infer
what customers like by you know how
often they go back to a page or how long
they look at an article these kind of
things
and then when we take that we have we
were able to kind of correlate the
what the item that someone's looking at
with other items that they look at next
and this we put into a system and
basically what we draw out of that
is a list of products or services
that our customers that actively based
on their current behavior
are interested in buying when they look
at this product or service
and then when we get a customer and they
look at a product we can then recommend
them
you know one of these um alternative or
complementary
products so it's it's real value there
you know
it helps you to upsell cross-sell it
helps you to build a better customer
experience
and there are many ways of actually
going about building this
um the way that we've looked at here is
really taking like you know the
canonical approach based on you know the
systems that we make available in google
cloud so bigquery for your data
warehouse
we're using uh google analytics data
which is a way to instrument your
website
in order to see you know what folks are
doing and how long they spend on page
which page they go to next all that kind
of stuff
like the click-through rates convergence
the things that are important to you to
analyze from your website we have a
service that brings that data into
bigquery
and then in bigquery as well we actually
have an ml
capability so we're able to generate
based on that analytics data
recommendations using a model matrix
factorization in this case
and generate that list of
recommendations per
product and now here's the great thing
it's not just
you know as i said it's not just about
creating that list or getting those
insights the next step is how to
activate that so when you look at
prolonged video as well
well you'll see the whole journey here
how to get the data
how to you know do the the preparation
of the data
how to um train the model
and then how to do the predictions and
then how to activate that and
so you know you might be asking yourself
like okay that sounds like a lot of work
how long is it going to take well as i
said
the sample data all the code is there i
would set you know
someone a challenge and say you know
spend a couple of hours running through
the sample
and then based on our sample data and
this you'll be generating those
recommendations
and then you know follow the steps on
how to customize and and you know add in
your own data
and then before you know it you'll be
looking at your own data you know and
and your own analytic data and start
generating generating recommendations
for your own company
that is great so all these come with a
simplified
two-pager that is going to allow you to
really uh you know structure your
deployment
simplify your approach and then scale
this inside your organization we're
putting the link down here
of all the other ones that are available
to you we hope that you're going to
enjoy them
we hope that they're going to help you
accelerate value inside your
organization and of course
is there any that you would like us to
build for us or you'd like to find out
more about how other customers are
building
let us know simply by putting a comment
down here robert thank you so much for
staying up late uh to talk to us about
this
i'm sure lots of people are going to
reach out to you we'll talk to you soon
you're welcome thanks a lot bruno bye